this is good work Steve I know it is cuz
I don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
[Music]
hi everyone its charlie we learned about
more alternate endings and more deleted
scenes from Avengers end games we'll
break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's a new
round of that spider-man far from home
imax ticket giveaway - all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a Spider Man or Avengers comments on the
video so obviously careful for spoilers
for Avengers endgame if you haven't seen
the movie yet there's a whole bunch of
these scenes so we'll just do this top
15 style starting with number 15 an
alternate ending for Iron Man vs.
Stannis's fight when Iron Man yoinks all
the Infinity stones when Thanos isn't
looking from the original start tech
gauntlet to his own armor suit and he
says I am Iron Man very iconic line in
the original version of that scene he
was gonna give him the middle finger and
drop an epic f-bomb Robert Downey jr.
actually had to be talked into saying I
am Iron Man originally he didn't want to
say that line but while they were
shooting in while they were editing it
they went out to dinner with some of the
producers in another one of their
friends who just happened to be Joel
Silver a very powerful producer in
Hollywood told Robert Downey jr. you
absolutely have to say that line I am
Iron Man and so Robert Downey jr. was
convinced they went right away and shot
it and that's how it wound up in the
movie which i think is much better than
the alternative even though it's really
cool to see Iron Man I drop an f-bomb to
Thanos in a Marvel movie number 14
Iron Man originally went to Asgard with
Thor during the events of thought of the
dark world so they could steal both the
reality stone aether in the tesseract
space stone because for a little while
during the events of that movie there
were two Infinity stones on Asgard
they've been keeping the tesseract there
ever since the first Avengers film they
had a huge Iron Man vs. Heimdall fight
with the younger version of Heimdall
Lebowski Thor would have faced off
against his younger self but Andrews
Elba wasn't available and it was going
to be a much longer scene with Natalie
Portman because she's barely in the
final version of the movie but there
were a lot of other things that they
changed about what they were doing with
this version of Thor during endgame so
that also changed some of the things
that they did during the Thor the dark
world scenes originally he didn't spend
quite as much time with his mother so
they leaned a little bit harder to that
in the final version of the film 13
there was a scene where they're in the
lobby of the Avengers tower in the
middle of the movie with the tesseract
in instead of Robert read
Alexander Pierce in the Hydra characters
is a younger version of Nick Fury in
Maria Hill that were trying to take the
tesseract from this version of Iron Man
number 12 the original final battle
scene was way way longer they said it
had its own three act structure
beginning middle and end because it was
so big like a movie within a movie just
for the final battle they said a lot of
that might wind up on the blu-ray but
after Hulk snaps everyone back and
Doctor Strange and Wong Portal everyone
to the battlefield to help Captain
America it was originally a much much
longer moment when all the heroes have
come back to life meet with the Avengers
who are still there in a series of
trenches to catch up on what's going on
and make a much more elaborate battle
plan but they said it slowed things way
way down because it turned into an
endless series of reunions with all the
characters we actually have some video
of this because Chris Evans was posting
from behind the scenes so this is him
just videoing them in between takes of
them in the trenches
there was a scene of iron man going into
the soul world of the soul stone after
he snaps all the fan OSes people away
just like fan OHS from infinity war went
into the soul world after he snapped
everyone the first time Thanos wound up
talking to a younger version of Gamora
piece of her soul but iron man wound up
talking to an adult version of his
daughter Morgan stark played by none
other than Catherine Langford everybody
wondered last year what she was doing in
the movie there were so many theories
but mystery solved she's playing an
older version of Morgan Stark they spent
a lot of time filming those scenes maybe
they'll also release that on the blu-ray
the whole point of the scene was meant
to be a mirror for Thanos is seen with
young Gamora where she says did you do
it what did it cost and he says
everything the Iron Man version of the
scene with Morgan Stark was meant to be
a little more positive and make him feel
better about sacrificing his life to
save everyone
because he knew that he was going to die
as cool as it sounds the reason why they
said they deleted it is because test
audience were too confused by adult
Morgan Stark they didn't recognize that
it was supposed to be her and it
completely destroyed the point of the
scene it completely took them out of the
movie
number 10 speaking of young Thanos there
were a lot more scenes of younger Thanos
showing you how much more powerful he
was than older Thanos from infinity war
because this was supposed to be a fan
oohs in his prime at peak physical
condition the reason why they explained
older Thanos from infinity war was a
weaker is because when he starts his
quest for the stones it takes him a
couple years to work up to that he stops
training the way that he used to so he's
not getting the conditioning and he sort
of puts down a lot of his weapons like
he has this giant blade that he fights
them with because it's still younger
Thanos going around planet to planet
erasing half of all life the old-school
way just doing it one planet at a time
they also explained that by the end of
infinity war day knows the older version
of Thanos has grown weaker because each
of the Infinity stones SAP a little bit
of his lifeforce when he adds them
that's part of the idea that only Thanos
and Hulk are powerful enough to survive
the gauntlet itself because even just
one Infinity stone is almost too much
for a normal person 9 there was another
version of the final scene where Thor
names Valkyrie queen of Asgard but it
was a little too comedic so they cut it
it was Thor leaning in to try and kiss
her after
thanks him for naming her queen she
winds up bashing him on the head I'm
actually glad that they cut that because
the door scene with the guardians of the
galaxy at the end was funny enough as
guardians of the galaxy 8 it was an
extra scene of spider-man and Hulk
during Iron Man's funeral scene at the
end where spider-man was going full
science prose with professor Hulk but it
got cut obviously because it was meant
to be a really a serious moment
reflecting on Iron Man's passing so
total tonal mismatch 7 there was an
entire subplot with Black Widow between
the snap in the beginning of avengers
endgame where she was sort of shut in
the avengers facility and wasn't leaving
but she had been running a special
program to find homes for all the
orphans of people who had lost their
parents to ben snap because it was a
random a lot of kids would wind up
losing both of their parents so you just
have a lot of little kids running around
almost these ashes just wondering what
the hell's going on 6 there was a whole
big different sequence of ant-man
visiting a bunch of different cities
after he came back so he visits the
memorial and they just cut it at that
after that he would have gone to a bunch
of different places to see what was
going on
Thor originally doubled down on his
vengeance remember he was out for
revenge against Thanos at the beginning
of infinity war after he killed Loki and
half of his people so originally they
were gonna have him go down a more
Hawkeye path where he goes way more
hardcore he gives himself a crazier buzz
cut but they decided to take him down
the trauma route because they were
already doing Ronan with Hawkeye and
they didn't want to be redundant like
that so for a very brief period you had
really really crazy out there Thor by
the Hawkeye scene at the opening of the
movie was supposed to happen at the end
of infinity war remember when we're
going around to all the characters after
the snap happens and you see their
friends or their loved ones get snapped
away Hawkeye was going to watch his
family die but they moved that to the
beginning of avengers endgame because
jeremy renner said the whole reason why
he wasn't an infinity war is because he
wanted to take a year off to be with his
family so he asked them to write him out
of infinity war so big hawkeye mystery
solved everybody all the memes wondering
where his Hawkeye why isn't he in the
movie turns out Jeremy Renner asked them
to do that so that he could have a break
before they started endgame for more
Hawkeye deleted scenes Hawkeye was
originally supposed to die on Boromir
when they're battling it out to see
who's gonna sacrifice themself for the
soul stone and they go back and forth or
Hawkeye was going to die the way they
rationalized the choice of black widow
though is they said that black widow
wouldn't let him sacrifice himself
because he still had his family to care
for three there's a different scene of
them breaking into the shield
headquarters to steal the tesseract
instead of them going back to 1977 so
originally the plot of Iron Man going
back to have that moment with his father
because that's the whole reason that
they go back to the 70s so that he can
have that moment with Howard Stark but I
think it's way better in the way that
they did it during the final version of
the movie and you get that really cool
Stan Lee cameo - there was a scene where
they travel to dr. Strange's apartment
before he became sorcerer supreme
remember when holt goes to the Ancient
Ones she says you're a couple years too
early dr. Strange's a couple blocks down
the street at the hospital it was a
scene where they were supposed to go
across town to go to his apartment in
number one there was a huge big
underwater set piece on Morag when they
went to get the power stone during the
events of the first Guardians film I
think the idea was is that they went
back too far in the water had not
receded because remember up until the
beginning of the guardians of the galaxy
films that area had been submerged
underwater so I think that they just
traveled back to the wrong place and
that's why they had to go underwater to
get the Power Stone they also did say
you know a bit of a bonus item that
Professor Hulk was supposed to be a
thing during Avengers infinity war and
it would have been a bigger moment but
they decided just to push it to Avengers
endgame but let me know in the comments
what your favorite deleted scene and
what are you hoping that they put on the
blu-ray but what will happen is is we're
getting ready for Comic Con next month
we'll learn about what's going on during
Marvel phase four d23 all the disney
plus avengers TV shows the Star Wars
Mandalorian TV show I'll be doing videos
for all that stuff but leave your
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video ones might
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for that brand new spider-man far
from home trailer and some venom news
and click here for my new avengers v
Marvel phase four video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
see you guys
you